alors il a été retrouvé à son domicile
vendredi dernier ce sont trois voisins
qui ont fait la
macabre découverte il se demandait ce
qui se passait parce que ça faisait deux
jours que les volets étaient fermés il y
avait pas trop de signes de vie autour
de son domicile donc ils se sont permis
d'y aller et c'est là qu'ils ont
retrouvé son corps dans l'arrière cours
de son domicile c'est les voisins qui
l'ont retrouvé trois de ses voisins
d'accord
on a parlé à un moment on va le dire on
a entendu Michel cordes assassiné on a
entendu plein de versions Gilles Verdez
bien entendu c'était quoi on a entendu
plein de versions comme ça on va revenir
sur la vraie version dans un instant
pour ça célébrité pour la brutalité de
ce qui s'est passé et puis à un moment
on a même entendu le mot de mafia c'est
ça même entendu il aurait été tué par la
mafia c'est parti très vite
ça a vite été écarté mais la deuxième
thèse qui est au départ pouvait être
exploré la deuxième piste c'était celle
d'un cambriolage qui aurait mal tourné
pourquoi parce qu'il y a eu un
cambriolage dans le quartier dans la
périphérie donc les gendarmes qui sont
arrivés à l'été par les voisins ont
commencé à enquêter sur ces pistes et
puis finalement ils ont a priori écarté
toutes ces pistes pour privilégier la
thèse du suicide Cyril d'accord
il allait pas très bien ces derniers
temps pourquoi qu'est-ce qui se passait
non il allait pas très bien
effectivement et c'est voisins ont
témoigné on observé un changement de
comportement ces dernières semaines
notamment son ancienne propriétaire qui
était toujours en contact avec lui et
qui a confié qu'elle l'avait trouvé
vraiment beaucoup moins bien moralement
depuis son divorce il s'est séparé de sa
compagne il y a un mois et cette
séparation elle intervient aussi
quelques mois après l'arrêt de Plus
belle la vie on sait que ça avait été
très brutale pour pour la corde il avait
dit qu'il n'avait pas compris la
décision de France Télévisions d'arrêter
le feuilleton il aurait aimé continuer à
jouer le rôle de Roland merci
il avait dit qu'il voulait ralentir le
rythme et que
ouais qui voulait continuer mais
c'est vrai que ça a été un gros coup
pour lui l'arrêt de Plus belle la vie je
crois la mort fictive sa mort fictive
dans la série d'abord juste avant
l'arrêt on a les images un double choc
c'est vrai que voilà il est il a eu un
parce que dans qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans la série il meurt et donc ça voilà
il n'a pas compris pourquoi il a été
évincé à ce moment-là le permet vincer
correspond bien de la série même si il a
dit après j'ai des projets etc de la vie
des témoins ça a été très compliqué
c'est ça c'était oui oui pour lui au de
18 ans ouais c'est très choquant c'est
ça quand vous tournez tous les jours
vous créez une famille une nouvelle
famille vous êtes bien avec eux parce
que c'était quand même un grand
solitaire sauf que les derniers temps il
a trouvé une jeune femme une femme
retraitée d'ailleurs comme lui une
inconnue
mais il a rencontré quelqu'un récemment
elle l'a planté d'accord elle est partie
entre tellement récemment ah oui très
récemment oui d'après ce que dit
l'ancienne propriétaire sa maison avec
laquelle il est resté très ami
d'ailleurs c'est marrant lâcher cette
baraque et j'ai très amis avec les
anciens propriétaires qui recevaient à
dîner et tout ça il était très ouvert
tout le quartier le disait très ouvert
très sympathique et très agréable parce
que c'est vrai que tout le monde veut
savoir ce qui s'est passé et tout le
monde a dit voilà il a eu énormément de
mal encaisser la fin de Plus Belle La
Vie évidemment il y a eu cette rencontre
derrière qui l'a remis un petit peu
voilà cette rencontre avec cette femme
c'était après la réplique Plus Belle La
Vie bouleversement émotionnel oui et
bouleversement personnel donc ça a fait
beaucoup et d'ailleurs les voisins qui
le connaissaient bien il était très très
bien connu dans le voisinage les voisins
ont trouvé changé les voisins ont dit
tiens ils se replient un petit peu etc
et quand ils ont vu effectivement les
volets fermés ils se sont dit qu'est-ce
que se passe-t-il parce que jamais une
fermeture de suite les volets alors il y
a un truc fou c'est qu'il aille laissé
plusieurs lettres une à sa fille c'est
ça oui c'est ça il a quatre enfants on
sait le contenu de la lettre non la
famille n'a pas voulu communiquer
pour dire que c'était voilà sans doute
on n'a pas le contenu mais c'est sans
doute pour expliquer c'est ça
volontairement voilà mis fin à ces jours
voilà et une office il y a une dernière
lettre il a écrit une lettre office
pourquoi on sait pas est-ce que c'est
pour régulariser ses affaires est-ce
qu'il y avait quelque chose derrière ça
pour le moment on ne sait pas mais c'est
vrai que l'ordonnancement du lieu avec
ces lettres à l'intérieur font que il y
aura bien entendu une autopsie pour
connaître que là qui pour connaître les
causes de la mort mais très
vraisemblablement la thèse du suicide se
dégage mais donc une lettre office que
c'est quoi il avait des problèmes
le fils que n'a jamais fait savoir qu'il
avait des problèmes financiers et puis
on peut imaginer que après 18 ans de
tournage de Plus belle la vie on sait
qu'il pouvait toucher jusqu'à 1000 euros
par jour pour son rôle donc
c'est plutôt la piste genre moi d'une
détresse émotionnelle ça peut être aussi
pour comme on dit mettre de l'ordre dans
ses affaires pour écrire pour prévenir
etc c'est tout ça paraît très préparé
pour le moment de feuilleton 2004 à 2022
77 ans il s'est donc ce serait donc
donné la mort en l'état des informations
dont nous disposons Michel corne ce
serait volontairement de donner la mort
par armes à feu à son domicile par arme
à feu arme à feu et les voisins pensent
même ils l'ont dit aux enquêteurs qui
les gendarmes abondent dans cette
hypothèse c'est que il a tout fait
effectivement pour être découvert il a
tout fait pour être découvert les volets
fermés ça attire l'attention des voisins
le portillon le petit portillon ouvert
donc à ce moment là les voisins se
disent il y a-t-il eu cambriolage comme
on a eu récemment dans le quartier donc
ils sont entrés et ils l'ont trouvé dans
l'arrière cours voilà comme s'il avait
voulu très vite hé
las et brutalement tragiquement qu'on le
découvre à ramassé c'est c'est très
brutal oui c'est très brutal c'est c'est
non pour le moment
toujours le parquet de Montpellier a
ouvert une enquête
dans les dans les prochains jours alors
forcément ça a été vraiment
l'information la triste information de
ce week-end
parce qu'on a des nouvelles de ses
proches non aucune nouvelle de ses
proches ceux qui ont réagi sont ces fans
évidemment vont c'était une figure
populaire de la télévision il était
vraiment très aimé plus belle la vie
c'est le feuilleton le plus long de la
télévision française il a tourné 4500
épisodes il était là depuis 2004 donc
c'était vraiment le pilier de la série
oui c'était la figure emblématique donc
évidemment ça a été un choc pour les
fans qui avaient déjà été très touché
par sa mort fictive donc là évidemment
ça a été très dur et le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron et Brigitte
Macron ont même réagi exactement en le
qualifiant de comédiens de cœur a rédigé
un communiqué de presse pour rendre
hommage à l'acteur pour vous dire pour
des millions de Français Michel corde
était un sourire un visage un rôle celui
de Roland Marci patron du bar Le Mistral
dans Plus belle la vie derrière cette
incarnation et cette façon cette façon
se dissimuler un homme sensible et
discret qui nous a quitté le 5 mai 2023
à l'âge de 77 ans
voilà donc c'est fou alors ils ont fait
un long communiqué en 2004 ce fut plus
belle la vie qui est le révéla au grand
public tous les soirs à 20h10 et pendant
18 ans son comptoir marseillais fut le
point névralgique des intrigues et des
passions car le personnage de Roland
figurait avec accent bonhomy et humanité
un art de vivre et une convivialité dans
lequel des millions de téléspectateurs
se reconnaît
ils ont ils ont fait un très long comme
d'ailleurs ils ont bien perçu tout de
suite le côté
identification et proximité c'est à dire
18 ans dans la télévision chez les gens
il y a une grosse identification et une
proximité parce qu'il était le
personnage emblématique auquel on se
référer tout le temps donc voilà alors
est-ce que les acteurs on n'a pas pu
avoir parce que je vous le dis tous les
acteurs peuvent pas parler pour la
famille par respect pour la famille
actuellement assez simple ils veulent
pas ils veulent pas
à réagir moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est
qu'il y a quand même celui qui incarne
Thomas dans la série donc le fils de
Michel corde qui n'a pas vraiment
apprécié l'hommage de Fabienne Cara qui
elle incarnée Samia Nasri elle a publié
un long texte assez bouleversant et il a
commenté sur Instagram en disant que
Michel n'aurait pas aimé cette hommage
pourquoi il n'a pas donné davantage
d'éléments mais oui c'est assez
particulier et puis il y avait aussi un
des témoins un des voisins de Michel qui
disait qu'il avait été très surpris que
Michel reçoivent très peu de visites des
acteurs de Plus belle la vie
après
il était vraiment très seul
il savait qu'il était est-ce que
quelqu'un savait qu'il était dans une
détresse psychologique ou pas du tout
visiblement les voisins l'ont trouvé
changé depuis quelques temps parce que
sa famille ses amis pour le moment la
famille resterait discrète est-ce que
les voisins parle beaucoup et ils sont
merci à eux d'ailleurs
il disait que ils étaient inquiet car le
port ont été ouvert et les volets
étaient fermés depuis deux jours il est
entrover ce qui n'arrivait jamais ce que
vous dites donc il voulait faire savoir
les volets étaient fermés depuis deux
jours alors avec ma femme et une voisine
nous sommes allés voir ce qui se passait
on redoutait notamment à cambriolage
après un précédent dans le quartier la
porte de la maison était fermée mais pas
verrouillé ils ont donc pu rentrer les
voisins ils sont allés ils ont leur
découvert le corps de Michel sanvier à
l'arrière de la bâtisse et il y avait
une marque rouge à latence que je vous
demandais tout à l'heure puisque
apparemment il se serait tué par arme à
feu d'un
revolver qui a été retrouvé juste à côté
de son corps et d'une balle dans la
tempe c'est quand même c'est très brutal
et ce qui se passe c'est que c'est un
petit village près de Montpellier Cyril
donc tout le monde se connaît et c'est
vrai que les gens avaient l'habitude de
parler avec lui depuis quelques temps il
était beaucoup plus recroquevillé voilà
il avait il était perturbé donc une
balle dans la tête ce serait mis une
balle dans la tête ils ont trouvé le
revolver un peu plus tard dans la
journée qui aurait suivi au suicide qui
ont servi au suicide ils l'ont retrouvé
bien sûr
et selon ce même voisin
il dit avec le recul Michel avait donc
tout préparé organisé pour qu'on le
découvre plus plus facilement du monde
ces derniers temps il était moins
bavards lorsque je le croisais ne tenait
plus à conversation et voici environ un
mois il disait qu'il n'avait pas le
moral qu'avec sa compagne il s'était
séparé et qu'elle comptait bien plus que
tout
et certains de ses amis ont pris la
parole voici un mois et demi environ je
l'ai senti un peu moins bien moralement
sa nouvelle compagne en instance de
divorce venez finalement de rompre avec
lui il était triste mais de la penser
une chose pareille sûrement pas il avait
dit après l'arrêt de la série j'ai des
projets et tout ça mais pour le moment
c'est projet était balbutiants il y
avait pas grand chose donc c'était
quelqu'un qui contrairement à ce que
pensait tout le monde était reclus dans
une certaine solitude alors pour
répondre à votre question Cyril il y
aura bien entendu toutes les expertises
à l'expertise balistique autopsie etc
mais c'est vrai que honnêtement la thèse
du suicide à l'heure où on parle ne fait
pas de doute c'est pas de doute on les
enquêteurs non alors comme vous l'avez
dit énormément de réactions bien entendu
des autres acteurs de Plus Belle La Vie
Jérôme Bertin qui joue le capitaine
Patrick Nebout publier j'ai l'impression
que ce soit tous ceux qui ont connu fait
regarder mes plus belles la vie sont
orphelins Michel notre Roland nationale
est comme un papa pour nous tous c'est
vrai que c'est on a l'impression que
c'est une fin tragique de Plus Belle La
Vie et une fin tragique de de l'acteur
principal de cette série on est relié
vraiment c'est un c'est c'est fou c'est
c'est oui parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
avec qui on s'identifiait presque été
éminemment populaire c'est le personnage
central d'une série de 18 ans qui
disparaît tragiquement et brutalement
donc l'émotion a effectivement a duré
depuis quatre jours c'est une émotion
considérable pour que la présence de la
République réagisse c'est que il s'est
passé quelque chose de tragique et
dramatique voilà honnêtement ça touche
tous les Français tous les Français sont
touchés par ce drame mais vous vous
rendez compte de la violence du truc
quand même le gars a travaillé
extrêmement populaire tous les jours
pendant 18 ans sur un plateau de
télévision c'était plutôt un solitaire
on arrête la série on le fait mourir de
crise cardiaque tout ça même
psychologiquement est assez violent bon
le mec du coup il rachète une petite
maison il s'y installe il est tout seul
il retrouve quelqu'un ce quelqu'un là
malheureusement elle a sûrement ses
raisons elle est partie imaginez la
solitude en plus il n'a pas eu 50
propositions de tournage entre temps et
en plus il est très catalogué dans cette
série c'est un métier extrêmement
difficile on se rend pas compte et que
peut-être la lettre office un moment
quand on gagne de l'argent comme ça
quand on passe à la télé oui quand on
passe à la télé après pendant quand vous
voulez rien ne rentre les frais ils sont
là et oui mais c'est important on y
pense
qu'il a connu tous ces traversées
vous gagnez des sous un petit moment et
après il y a plus rien les charges sont
les mêmes et paf c'est très compliqué à
vivre c'est dur à supporter moi je le
trouve ça très triste parce qu'il est
éminemment sympathique et que tout le
monde l'aimait vraiment il a tout perdu
en très peu de temps en fait il était
très populaire il était dans un
feuilleton qui l'adorait je pense que
Plus belle la vie on a vraiment cette
image très familiale il était le
patriarche il était tout le temps
entouré de tous ces acteurs et même de
la nouvelle génération
qui ont enfin tous les jeunes acteurs
aussi ça lui et sa sagesse et sa
sympathie il était vraiment présenté
comme quelqu'un de très simple et je
pense que de retourner comme ça à
l'anonymat et ensuite
subir une déception amoureuse une
déception sentimentale et un divorce ça
fait beaucoup d'un coup et réaliser
aussi que c'est pas de vraies familles
quand on tourne avec des gens même
pendant des années c'est ça se rend
compte que pasta le terminal est terminé
on voit plus personne
c'est ça qu'on se demande